it was about it was about 790
um per month and it's up to 1400
the 1450 now where are you finding the
extra money this is basically the extra
hours we work cutting back on
things that maybe we would have done
before the bit of money that we were
putting aside for a rainy day you know
we're on a contract and obviously we
work outside of our contract doing extra
hours
how many hours a week do you work now
well we're on a 39 hour contract and um
we're probably doing double that maybe
more it's just I just can't believe in
this day and age so you know we're
having to live like this you know not
just me a lot of people
you know surely if you're working hard
and you know you should be sort of
ripping the rewards and uh and having a
certain standard of living and it's just
just not happening for for many people